[Music]
foreign
[Music]
this is DW news live from Berlin
finland's prime minister and the
president announced their support for
NATO membership it's the first step in a
move that would end Decades of military
non-alignment popular opinion in the
country has swung in favor of joining
the Western Alliance since Russia's
invasion of Ukraine also on the program
Kiev offers a prisoner swap to get
seriously wounded to Fighters out of the
embattled steel plant in mariopol
offering to hand over Russian prisoners
of war in exchange
and North Korea confirms an outbreak of
kobit 19 for the first time a national
lockdowns ordered after the fast
spreading Omicron variants is reported
in the capital Junior
[Music]
I'm Phil Gale welcome to the program
finland's president and prime minister
have called for the country to apply for
NATO membership as soon as possible in a
joint statement asyloninisto and
salamarin said NATO membership would
strengthen finland's security as a
member of NATO Finland would strengthen
the entire defense Alliance Finland must
apply for NATO membership without delay
this is the first step in a process that
could see the country roll back Decades
of military non-alignment the
announcement is expected to put pressure
on Sweden which is also considering
applying to join the defense Alliance
now Finland shares a 1300 kilometer
border with Russia the mood in the
country has changed dramatically since
moscow's invasion of Ukraine
[Music]
War Games to secure the peace more than
3 000 Finnish troops and 700 Vehicles
took part in the Aero 22 military
exercises in Western Finland
the exercises were conducted with NATO
as planned last Autumn armed forces from
five countries are taking part in these
military exercises the host Finland is
not a NATO member yet but that could
change soon
for the first time in their history the
majority of Finns want to join NATO a
turning point in history keenly felt by
people in LA penrata on the border with
Russia
for decades they have benefited from
living in peace with their neighbors
welcoming a steady stream of Russian
tourists from nearby Saint Petersburg
says social worker Linda Brandt my I
never saw Russia as a threat but now I'm
constantly thinking about our common
border it's over a thousand kilometers
this nearby border crossing is seeing
little traffic from either side at the
moment
this is partly due to coronavirus
related restrictions but it's also a
direct consequence of Russia's invasion
of Ukraine
the war has dramatically changed the
Finn's attitude towards joining nato in
just a few weeks
I thought we shouldn't get involved in
military alliances but now I think we
should have made the decision a long
time ago
my eyes have been opened and I no longer
see NATO as some kind of War Association
but as a defense Alliance
defense through deterrence has been the
principle behind NATO's reinforcement of
its eastern Flank In recent months the
idea being a strong defense will not be
attacked
Neto says it will benefit from The
Finnish Army's military capabilities I
think we are ready ready to to enter the
NATO if the system will be made we have
been training together with the good
partners which are basically NATO
Partners you know exercises for for
years so that shouldn't be a problem
at the moment Finland is a native
partner but not a member of the block
nevertheless Finnish forces have worked
closely with the NATO for decades
I hope that we will join NATO as soon as
possible
and that the war in Ukraine will end
soon and that Europe will live in peace
and stability
believes joining nature would help
people in the small Border Town of
lampen rata feel safer she says that now
a peaceful and stable Finland is only
possible as a NATO member
let's have a look at these movements
then with Alexander stud who was
finished prime minister between 2014 and
2015. now welcome to DW there are lots
of people who say that today's
announcement from the president and
prime ministers long overdue what's your
feeling
well certainly I've been an advocate of
Finnish NATO membership for the better
part of 30 years probably one could say
that better late than never and I must
say that this will go down in history as
NATO's ninth enlargement which is pretty
much Putin's enlargement without his
attack on Ukraine I don't think the
Finnish public opinion would have
changed as radically as it has so what
methods do you think this sends to
Vladimir Putin
well I think the president of Finland
salinity said it quite well yesterday
you know all you need to do is in
Kremlin is look in the mirror it sends a
message that when Finns and sweets feel
unsafe they seek for security elsewhere
now the good news of course is that
we're more NATO compatible than most
NATO States we have reserves of 900 000
we have mobility of 280 000 we have 62
f-18s and soon 64 F-35 so we're very
much a security asset for the alliance
it's a win-win for Nordic Security
Baltic Sea security European security
and the alliance it's interesting though
that Russia Annex Crimea in 2014 while
you were prime minister so why do you
think it is it is it has taken um Putin
launching an all-out war on Ukraine for
for Finland to send this message to
Russia finally
we should probably go a little bit
further I was foreign minister in 2008
and chairman of the osc uh and together
with French foreign minister Bernard
Kushner we broke her to ceasefire in
Georgia in five days uh that was the
first warning signal after that in a
speech called zero eight zero eight zero
eight I called for a reassessment of
Finnish NATO membership but I got a very
strong pushback 2014 I don't think
Europe and the West reacted strongly
enough but when you go into full-scale
conventional Warfare when you kill
innocent human beings women and children
that's when people react and that's
where I think Putin made a tactical and
strategic mistake which he's now paying
for all right and let's look at the the
Russian reaction to this news because
we've heard from the Russian foreign
Ministry are saying that Finland joining
NATO is a radical change in the
country's foreign policy they go on to
say Russia will be forced to take
retaliatory steps both of a military
Technical and other nature in order to
stop threats to its National Security
what's your reaction to that
normal Russian rhetoric remember Finns
are cool calm and collected we don't get
flustered by much so we'll see a lot of
cyber attacks and probably information
wars in the next few days information
was the type of stuff that you just had
there but we'll get that in Finland in
Sweden and then also and this is a
warning to all of our future NATO
Partners there'll be a lot of
disinformation about Finland joining
NATO but we are not excessively worried
nothing is going to happen on the
Eastern flank because of Finland joining
NATO this is an interesting mindset that
the the closer you are to potential
danger the more you sort of get used to
it because as well as what the Kremlin
has said today we've heard the the the
Moscow repeatedly warning that it might
deploy nuclear weapons if Finland and
Sweden was to join NATO so you see this
as just more Russian saber rattling
no it's actually fake news I mean we
need to remind the president former
president Medvedev that the nuclear
missiles are already there and cleaning
right around the Baltic Sea region but
this is the way in which Russia is
trying to intimidate Finland and Sweden
out of the decision to joining NATO of
course the reverse will happen so the
more there are threats the more
popularity for NATO membership increases
remember when this war started we were
down to about 20 percent of the
population in favor of NATO membership
with Russian action and threats we are
now up to 76 and now with the Prime
Minister President coming out today
we're going to be north of 80 in favor
of NATO membership juxtaposed that with
our EU referendum 1994 57 in favor 43
not so don't mess with Finnish security
I guess is what the Finnish public is
trying to tell Russia okay and and it's
as as neighbors this is such a really
interesting and complex history you have
a 1300 kilometer border um the
relationship has has been fractious but
you have stayed out of the western
military alliances until now so where do
you see the relationship going from here
well I think for the foreseeable future
so we're talking a few years ahead we
will see an isolated Russia and more or
less 40 European Democracies on the
other side of the feds but of course as
you said we have 1 340 kilometers border
with Russia our security policy is
always based on a careful assessment of
two things idealism and realism idealism
in the sense that Bonafide we want to
cooperate with Russia and make them part
of the west but realism we upkeep one of
the largest militaries uh in Europe
that's the reality on the ground you
know we've always reacted to situations
in 1809 we maximized autonomy in 1970 we
declared independence in 1944 we
reluctantly accepted peace and lost 10
percent of our country in 1992 we
applied for EU membership and now in
2022 we apply for NATO membership and
the only reason for this is who this put
this aggression
so that's the headline the headline is
that it looks like the country is in
favor of of uh applying to join NATO do
you anticipate any significant
objections domestically or indeed
amongst NATO members
answer no and no domestically this is a
foregone conclusion listen all parties
are now basically in favor Parliament is
going to vote in favor I'd guess about
180 out of 200 MPS next Wednesday so
that that is clear on the 30 uh NATO
member states we accept a fairly rapid
ratification probably the quickest in
the history of NATO membership and the
reason for that is that Finland and
Sweden are as compatible to Nato as can
be and I think all the countries in NATO
see us as a security asset rather than a
cost and in that sense we will it's a
win-win for us for the Baltic Sea region
and for the alliance so no problems with
that front either that's very clear good
talking to you thank you so much for uh
joining us Alexander stubb a former
prime minister of Finland